all right now some of the best college
players are also in las vegas playing
right now at the east west shrine game
and that's where we find john treach
over to legion stadium where there are
about 40 different universities
represented there john
you're right chris for 97 years some of
the best college players in the world
have played in this game and gone on to
be professional football hall of famers
and college football hall of famers but
this game truly has life-changing
ramifications for so much more beyond
the field especially with our young
people and i'm joined by two national
patient uh ambassadors sydney and seth
and sydney why is this game so important
to you this game is so important to us
especially for shriners and the children
that receive care at shriners because it
brings awareness to the hospital and the
amazing care that china has done for me
and for seth and we know what it's like
and the care that they give us so we're
really excited to bring awareness to
shriners and for everyone to come out
and watch the game
and it's so relatable we all know
uh kids who need help and you're gonna
play college golf
but without this hospital in this
organization you wouldn't have had this
opportunity seth
why has it changed your life i mean
without shriners i wouldn't be able to
play sports i wouldn't have a life with
relative discomfort i mean i would be
not half of who i am today without
shriners they've impacted me physically
and who i am as a person i'm so thankful
for what they have done for me awesome
and this hospital helps children
regardless of their ability to pay and
all the proceeds from this game go to
that cause so you got to love that and
so las vegas and is part of the
tradition now after 97 years reporting
from legion stadium john treach live
local now